review group led by one of scotland's
most senior judges has recommended that
a new specialist court
should be created to deal with serious
sexual offences now the recommendation
recommendations from lord justice clark
lady dorian
are aimed at making the experience for
victims less traumatic
now the report recommends the use of
pre-recorded evidence so that victims
don't need to keep repeating traumatic
stories a new
specialist court will be set up so
judges prosecutors and defenders will
get training
to deal with vulnerable witnesses and
the most dramatic
suggestion was a pilot where cases would
be heard
only by a judge with no jury now i ask
eddie dorian to explain more about her
report and the reasoning behind it
the main recommendation is for a
specialist
court to deal with all serious cases
of sexual assault or any other sexual
offences
and that that court should be staffed by
individuals who have had a particular
training trauma informed training
from the judges all the way down through
all the participants and that there
should be in addition to that as a
default feature of the court that the
evidence of complainers
in sexual cases should be captured
on video in advance of the trial well in
advance of the trial
one of the most eye-catching someone say
controversial
uh things to that you put forward as a
suggestion is that some trials could be
done
not by juries but by judges what is the
thinking behind that do you
basically not trust juries to always
give the right verdict
in some of these very sensitive cases
the the
reasoning behind that was that we are
dealing with in this review we're
dealing with the problem
about how these cases are managed that
has been with us for many many years
and we keep having similar discussions
about them
and in the course of our discussions we
looked at other options for
dealing with these cases other than
juries and considered that this was a
subject that needed to be
examined further so we're not
recommending that juries should be
abolished for these cases
we're simply saying that's a
conversation that needs to take place
and needs to be informed by
public discussion and is that because
you are worried that
rape myths or preconceptions i guess are
quite widespread among society
it's because we feel that the uh
idea that we simply carry on doing
things the way that we have always been
doing them isn't necessarily the best
way forward
and if we're exploring the idea of a
completely new court we should be
open to looking at all other options
that could be available
it's interesting to hear one of the
judges who's been quoted to say that in
some of these
sensitive cases where there's evidence
of equality and quantity which for any
other kind of crime would lead to a
conviction i
see a number of acquittals each year in
rape cases which to my mind
are not explicable by rational
application of the law to the evidence
is that something that you agree with
that's one of the
discussion points that uh featured
in the course of the debate about the
various options that were available
and was the view put forward in the
course of debate which
informed our eventual conclusion and do
you think the current
setup is perhaps biased against women in
any way
what we felt was that the current system
required
to be um improved so that the
complainers
men and women uh found that the
experience was
uh was less traumatic yeah it's
interesting we you talk about the
idea of it being traumatic the idea of
going through the whole process of
reporting
you know violent crime or or a rape
against yourself
one of the former chief constables of
nottinghamshire police told women's hour
this week
that she would hesitate before bringing
anything forward and
she would struggle she said to report a
crime against herself
because of what she described as the
endless repeated humiliation
i mean do you feel that too well one of
the factors that we
felt was necessary for us to look at
was whether there were aspects of the
way things are dealt with at the moment
which um did not assist complainers
to move on from having the experience
that they'd had
and which were capable of
re-traumatization
one of the most common uh issues that
arose in that discussion was that
people felt having to tell their
give their account repeatedly was
something which
was capable of re-traumatizing them and
so
we looked at whether we could start from
a position
that a court would adopt
trauma-centered trauma-based
approaches which would uh avoid that
and we've seen such an outpouring of you
know grief and anger after the
sarah everard's um death um in the uk
um do you feel that now is the time to
really start seriously looking
in scotland but also in other parts of
the uk as well about how we deal with
these
crimes against women girls well
obviously
cases of of murder would not be
part of the remit of our
review we were dealing only with sexual
offences
but one of the things that drove the
review was
the feeling that it was necessary to
look at
how these cases as a whole were managed
and that we could do better and if you
look at the conviction rates for rape
and also sexual offences
they've always been pretty low and it
feels like they're getting worse i mean
certainly
in england and wales over the last three
years rape convictions more than
halved do you think things are getting
worse
well we didn't proceed on the basis that
the conviction rate was a driving factor
in our report we proceeded
on the basis that what was necessary was
to find a better way of managing the
cases that
avoided traumatization we very
specifically
decided that we should not approach
matters on the basis that was any kind
of
appropriate conviction rate
or that convictions should be a marker
of success
so we adopted a completely different
approach which was simply to look
at the experience of those who were
complaining of sexual violence women or
men
has it been quite hard in your career to
have seen the impact
on some of these people who do come
forward yes some of the uh accounts
that we had uh that explained that
people
felt re-traumatized after their
engagement with the criminal justice
system
was one that was difficult for us to to
to hear because
clearly that is not the intention and
we had to listen to that and find a way
of
creating a system that would not do that
do you feel that rape has been
effectively decriminalized in the uk
because of the low conviction rates
uh i i don't think that's something that
was within the review
groups uh remit or that i can comment on
it's a crime that's taken very seriously
and it continues to be taken very
seriously and
this review shows how seriously we
intend to take it
okay thank you so much and thank you so
much for coming on and explaining some
of the details about the review as well